what are the top issues serverless
developers run into and how do they
resolve them Wes well I don't know
Martin but I have a feeling you're going
to tell me you betcha this is the 100th
episode of serverless expeditions we
will share the top three problems we've
heard about from serverless developers
and how to resolve them
[Music]
hey Martin well I've been thinking if I
had to guess I would say user
authentication is one of the top issues
that serverless developers run into and
you would be right Wes why is
authentication so difficult do you think
well I suspect it's because the very
first HTTP standard back in 1991 didn't
say anything about authentication as an
industry we've been playing catch-up
ever since but that's just my opinion
yeah that sounds about right also we
expect more Security today than back in
the 90s and that means security
standards keep evolving and changing as
a developer it can be difficult to keep
up well if there were only some YouTube
videos that explain how to do security
in a serverless way
right right I was getting there Wes if
you want a refresher on serverless
security check out these overview videos
we published in the series some time ago
I will link to all these videos in the
description below well Json web tokens
or jots provide a great way to
authenticate end users in your back end
you Chris shot a couple of videos about
how to use them with Firebase
Authentication yeah Json web tokens or
jot as you call them they're great for
public web applications but for company
internal apps you probably want to block
all external users and allow only
internal users identity aware proxy is a
great tool for that all right well I've
got to ask you about authentication no
no about that circuit board behind you I
see it in every video shoot what is it
oh this thing yeah this is actually a
board used by The seti Institute search
for extraterrestrial intelligence here
in Mountain View and they used it back
in the 90s they used it to look for
signals from extraterrestrials in the
output of radio telescopes well were the
people at the city Institute sad to see
their circuit board go well they have
much faster computers now and some City
projects process their data in the cloud
actually we have another video with one
of the researchers about that I bought
this board at an auction where the
proceeds went to fund future city
research at the auction I said though I
was looking forward to getting this
circuit board into my living room and uh
the spouse to one of the city scientists
said that they really looked forward to
getting it out of theirs I'm sure all
right well that was authentication when
I'm speaking at conferences people often
ask me how to connect their serverless
applications to databases yeah on one
hand it's great that there are multiple
databases in Google Cloud because they
all serve slightly different needs and
on the other hand it's confusing that
there are so many database products
exactly Wes so uh which are the
databases we most often see serverless
developers use well as a developer you
first have to ask yourself if you want a
relational or SQL database or a
non-relational nosql database right
relational SQL databases are good for
aggregating data over many records to
find averages counts maximums and so on
they're also good when money needs to
stored in database or when you have
complex data models Cloud SQL supports
MySQL postgres and SQL server but if you
want a fully managed relational database
with unlimited scale strong consistency
and up to five nines of availability you
should check out spanner yeah and
non-relational is good for internet
scale applications when your data model
is simple also the nosql database I use
most of the time cloud firestore is
completely serverless
I like that with firestore there's no
need to provision capacity up front I
can use it for just a trickle of traffic
or to access thousands of Records per
second and I only pay for the operations
and the storage that I actually use well
you shot a few videos about connecting
serverless applications the databases
didn't you yep some popular videos in
the serverless Expedition series dealt
with databases
that makes sense since almost all the
applications we build require a database
yeah but Martin have you ever written a
non-trivial application that didn't use
the database
uh yeah as a matter of fact I have a few
years ago I wrote a web service that
provided type ahead suggestions for city
names
so if the user typed s a n for example
that would get suggestions back like
Santiago San Antonio San Francisco and
so on yeah but I I thought you would
store all those city names in a database
for that yep I could have but city names
don't change very often so I just put
all of the names of the most populated
cities in the world into a single text
file and the file came out to about 20
megabytes and then I deployed my code
together with that text file with Cloud
run and then on Startup that code reads
all those city names from the text file
into memory for fast access yep that's
it keeping all the data in memory is
actually much faster than accessing a
database
now my turn to ask a question was what
is that map behind you over your right
shoulder uh it doesn't look like any map
I know oh this one well the reason why
you don't recognize it is because it's
an imaginary map it's a map of the Land
of Make-Believe and basically as a child
this was in my doctor's office upstairs
in the immunization Center and of course
you don't want little kids to think
about getting shots in their arms so
they distract them with a map like this
where you're just like looking over that
and not even thinking about getting a
shot
oh that's a neat story I I actually
didn't know the immunization part of the
story it's all about distracting the
kids huh that's right well now we've
actually talked about two or maybe three
big pain points including the shot in
the arm the kids get uh uh that most
developers have to deal with user
authentication and databases but there
is a third for developers oh Wes I was
hoping we'd be done no not yet only one
more to go developers often ask us how
to put authentication serverless
competing databases file systems and so
on together to design useful systems oh
kind of like technical architecture
that's right again Google Cloud offers
many tools and it's sometimes hard to
pick the right ones and connect them
correctly especially if you're new to
the cloud yeah if you choose the wrong
tools for your applications you might be
setting yourself up for a lot of extra
work yeah but we've released a number of
architecture videos as part of this
series and I think he shot a couple of
them with Dina right yep I did I think
those episodes were used useful to
developers because they got a lot of
views and a lot of comments and here are
some of them yeah so these videos are
all about designing the architecture for
your app not about coding your app right
that's right well you know me Wes I love
coding but in the beginning of the
project it's useful to take a step back
and sketch out your applications
architecture you will save the time in
the long run that makes sense all right
time for my next question Martin I see
two maps behind you one looks like
Scandinavia if I'm not mistaken but I
don't recognize the other one yeah
Scandinavia here and this one uh that
one is actually a 1608 map of Ireland by
an Italian named boazio okay that's
interesting but it doesn't really look
like Ireland
yeah that's because North is to the
right well isn't North usually up on
maps yep but this map was drawn before
that was a universal convention like it
is today uh back then cartographers put
North in the direction they felt like or
or whatever fit the page better well I
guess there's no law of physics that
says North has to be up right right
right it's just a convention and
sometimes conventions are really useful
because they help us communicate
and sometimes it's useful to challenge
our conventions for example we might
build serverless systems in the cloud
very differently than we'd build on-prem
systems that's right when your code runs
on a single machine you can keep user
sessions in memory between requests and
when you're using serverless every
request may end up on a different
instance so you have to put session
storage on another tier like maybe a
redis cache on a different machine now I
watched the video that you and Dina shot
about that one yeah I remember that one
that was a fun one I find that
developers who come from serverful
Computing often try to apply the tools
and techniques they use there on the
server full they try to use them on
serverless for example they want to
monitor server CPU well and that's not
really needed with serverless is it I
mean if Google notices that the CPU is
struggling or getting too much traffic
that we automatically spin up more
instances for you right yep that's right
serverless applications are easier to
manage because Google takes care of a
lot of the operations work like checking
your CPU
well when I asked about Ireland I knew
somehow you would stick cloud computing
in your answer yep you you got me worse
ah thank you everyone for watching the
100th episode of serverless expeditions
go build useful systems in the cloud
that solve real world problems and do it
serverlessly if you can that way Google
will configure and maintain the servers
so you don't have to indeed check out
the videos we talked about the links are
all in the description below also please
let us know in the comments what you
thought of today's episode and what
serverless topics we should bring up in
the future we read every single comment
until next time
[Music]